I'm Norman beer I am the director of the
open learning initiative and the
executive director of the Simon
initiative me when we talk about the
open learning initiative is both a
pioneering movement and open education
but also it is distinctly CMU it's
something I don't could have happened
any more but Carnegie Mellon so so yeah
so you got the chance to try this out at
in 110 right so I am required to take
110 as a psychology major I'm of wire
type 1 10 I totally thought what there
was a ridiculous requirement so I was a
little whiny about having to take it
because I heard all these you know
frightening stories um so I put off til
taking it to my senior year even though
like I had known this was the next
vacation since my freshman year and so
then I was like I was talking about
advisor about it and she was like you
know what do it over the summer if
you're this nervous because then you can
just pour all your focus into 110 um and
honestly like the experience I'm so I
now understand why to requirement for
psychology majors I kind of think it
should be requirement for everyone who
goes to CMU just because at least a lot
of times especially in the west coast
when I tell people I go to CMU every
single person's like oh you're an
engineer oh your computer science you
know person like well actually I'm
sitting psychology but you're right
you're one of our string yeah I was like
you're right a lot of my peers are so I
think it's really good because I I don't
know like the CMU label kind of comes
with this technical idea in this
technical background so now I feel like
I've participated even a super small
part of it like makes me feel like I
deserve the title a little more now I
think that's and one of the things was
trying to get out into the class was
that notion that you know you really are
participating and one of the men with a
lot of great traditions here but I think
that the the work we've done in CS is
just you know it's this enormous river
and maybe you're just dipping your foot
into it but you're a part of it now and
that's the really exciting I mean
obviously the course at least the way
that we were doing it in the summer and
I think them in the way it's being
introduced now in the in the in the
phone spring semesters is able to take
advantage of a lot of the work coming
out of the Simon initiative which
includes the oli courses and so I'm
curious how did that compare to some of
the other classes you've taken of
courses that didn't have the ability to
use some of the EdTech pieces i would
say in other classes where they didn't
use all I
which was pretty much every class except
for computing at CMU and if you took it
in the summer there wasn't even a
professor so this is cool because it
kind of combined having professors you
can ask questions too but also the oli
modules and that's different because I'm
not it was hard kind of doing that all I
completely on my own for the computing
at CM but with other classes I'd say
it's kind of tough like see you are
tired during lecture or something like
that or for some reason you miss a
lecture and lecture is really rich but
there's not really a way to get like
those notes and I feel like oli has like
a backup if something like that happen
it's not like you should miss lecture
anything but in the case that you do or
that something doesn't work out you're
able to go to the oli modules and you're
able to like kind of get caught up or
like at least get a buffer for what
you'd missed and I like that
accessibility to have that great yeah I
totally agree I think for me that oh I
was really helpful because I could do it
before class then I felt like I kind of
knew what I was getting into in class
and then if I ever was kind of confused
from the the in-class portion I knew
that like it wasn't the end I'll be
loved that moment like I had to learn
and understand in that moment like I had
time and structured time in which I
could learn it by myself or with the
guide of the ol I modules okay and did
you feel like the online materials in
the supporting tech blended fairly well
with with the traditional class time
yeah did we get those synced up fairly
well yeah I think so i think um the i
always loved at the end the question
that was like what do you want your
instructor to spend more time on because
at least the way you didn't you really
talked about that and you really use
that and that was it kind of made you
feel like you're learning experience was
like being valued and that like you
weren't necessarily expected to 100%
understand everything that had happened
during the oh I module or during class
yeah and I think if that's used properly
it can be pretty nice because I've just
been thinking about this semester people
do not like asking questions in lecture
at CMU because everybody's afraid that
you're there asking the dumb question
when in reality there has to be at least
one other person
lecture hall that feels the same way so
even though it would be nice to have
that problem be fixed it's nice because
this gives an opportunity where you
don't just like stay silent in fear of
being judged necessarily you can just
type in like hey like this is me to you
as my professor could you please spend
some more time on this whereas other
ways you might not have time to talk to
your professor about that after class in
some cases with a short 10 minute
transitions and I think it just comes in
handy to be able to at least get that
information across so I think there we
talk a lot about the availability of the
technology to eliminate the back row or
to bring the back row students forward
metaphorically and I think that that's a
piece of it right i mean it's but it's
also i think normalizing that piece of
learning that requires you to
acknowledge hey i don't know exactly
what's happening here i need to ask
questions and so it gives you a vehicle
for doing that and it ties it a little
more directly to what you've just
learned right so there's that close
relationship to have just had this
practice things unclear i can get that
information out and then hopefully
benefit from faculty so it's it's it's
affirming to hear that that's you know
that it plays out the way that it's
supposed to in the theory yeah i think
particularly the activity portion when
you're not graded on but there's the
check one at the end which is obviously
graded an important feedback from the
instructor but the the portion that you
know likes it goes you know appears
green if you've gotten a write or read
if you've gotten it wrong but that you
know you can kind of try it again makes
it a lot less intimidating because if
it's immediately graded then there's
you're still kind of stressed out right
the whole experience because you know
like this is a one-shot moment but the
thief the feedback I think in particular
is really helpful because most other
feedback you get in a classroom is
graded feedback just because that's the
nature of school but it kind of offers a
unique opportunity for non-graded
feedback for the activities was there
anything any specific pieces of it that
really stood out as you know what were
some of the best ones we tell me the
worst ones too is what really worked for
you I think for me the ones where you
could actually code in Python in the in
the module itself and it would give you
feedback I really appreciate it because
the whole idea of coding even literally
just sending enough on my computer was
intimidating to me so the fact that you
could do it just like in the web browser
in the module so the only thing you
needed to focus on with actually whether
your code was working or not was really
helpful to me and then I think the other
thing I appreciated especially about
that piece is that eat so if you got it
wrong it would give you a hint and it
would kind of like point you towards the
right answer but eventually like either
if you did eventually get your own
version right where your code ran or you
just really couldn't get it like the
right answer was eventually given to you
which i think is really important
because I think sometimes in classroom
settings professors don't want to give
the right answer because there's this
idea like oh you want the student to
figure it out themselves but if it's so
out of reach that they're never going to
get there by themselves then that really
only serves to intimidate the student
more because then they're like oh I'm
expected to eventually get to the right
answer and I am not so one thing I
really appreciate about what it was that
you did get the right answer in the end
and even if sometimes if I was really
stuck I would eventually get to the
right answer and then I would just look
at the right answer and I would just
rewrite it and that even helped me learn
the structure of it I think so one of
the other things that's important about
about the way that the larger Simon
initiative works is this ability to take
some of the data that's coming from your
experiences with these materials and
feed it back into the research space and
curious as to how that felt to you I
mean work through the consent form I
talked a little bit about this does that
change the experience at all is it does
it feel important to you I think it's
kind of cool to know that you're
participated in something like that um
and I think it makes I don't know I
think it's a little motivating because
like you want you want like to represent
you know the tip like a student that's
actually helpful you don't even like if
you like I don't know for me because I
felt like I was probably not in the
strongest half of the class like
understanding why I wanted to make sure
like I was still you know like carrying
through my part of the bargain even if I
wasn't understanding everything um so I
think it does i think it's like a
motivational thing for students I know
sometimes like I'm for research in sight
especially with younger kids like we
worry a lot about like what effect that
has on them like it's potentially
negative effect but I think especially
in like a research university it can
really only have a positive effect
because it means that you're learning
experience is being valued yeah you're
pretty you're participating in that
yes yeah it's kind of cool to be on the
front line or at least the liq a long
line of progress for a new initiative in
general just like I don't really think
like you can mention the consent form
doesn't really bother me to think that
like the way answer things like how I do
in the class is being like used in
research I mean like I said when I
whenever I didn't pass 112 it kind of
just had to be honest with people and I
think honesty is important and it's
important for learning as well so no big
deal whatsoever for me like if I have
some trouble in one area like that's
okay it's going to help students down
the road that that's actually helpful to
that right it means know a little bit
about how we can optimize learning
process for yeah i think that the so
beyond the oli pieces there were the the
tutors that sat outside so that's
actually a kelly rivers is a PhD student
here and she's been doing a lot of work
on how to build software that can
automatically give you hints and
feedback and the notion that what's
driving this research is students
participating in the work which is being
done by a student really yeah it creates
pretty exciting cycle it says that the
knowledge that's being that that's being
created here is actually being
co-created and the students are an
essential part of this right it changes
what a university community looks like I
think that's pretty neat yeah so how
imaginative play this kind of work more
broadly we could get more courses and
more materials out how do you think the
use of this kind of stuff could change
they experience at CMU I think it would
definitely allow students to like take
more responsibility of their learning
and that because they're given this
choice of when to engage in the material
it's a little bit more on them to engage
in the material outside of class and a
more kind of self-motivated way than for
a grade for instance um so I don't know
and I do think it really d stresses and
like the whole situation of morning
because you have this other opportunity
to learn that then incorporated into the
classroom yeah I think the really really
important thing for me um like I think
best conjunction was for sure having a
professor and oli on top of it but one
thing like students my friends and I've
been talking about even this year is
like each prefer
has a different style doing things some
professors make you feel overwhelmed by
how quickly they're moving through the
material and everything like that and as
I said before a lot of students aren't
going to be willing to say oh my gosh
like that was too fast can you please
slow down or can you say that again
because nobody wants to feel like the
odd one out that didn't understand
whatever the professor just said I think
it's definitely a better use of time to
be able to somehow use something like
oli to allow there to be more of a
connection between the professor and the
students at hand alright so I think
thanks for coming and being able to talk
about this I think the feedback is
really important and you know we talked
a lot about feedback loops inside of oli
and getting this kind of qualitative
feedback loops pretty important to the
work but you know thanks for coming in
as well because I haven't seen you in a
few weeks I'm glad you had a good summer
and it's good to see you back on campus
thank you appreciate the opportunity